hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of my YouTube viewers walks cabana
boy who wrote in I have a boxing
business and have no money for
advertising I mainly use postcards and
current clients do you have any ideas
for this type of business so it's a
service based business which is great a
lot of entrenar set up in the service
industry I think for you your best
opportunity will come from current
clients and over delivering so when you
start off your business it can be priced
competitively you want to make sure you
can attract people to come to the
business and maybe you do your post our
campaigns and you know partner up with
other businesses and maybe get a little
bit of media attention to get people
into the store but your best bet of
growing the business will be getting the
customers who do come in to come back
and to refer their friends and how this
happens is by what we're delivering so
whatever you can do think of ways to add
as much value as you can to that
experience so that they can't wait to
come back and tell their friends about
it as well so a quick example from my
own experience hopefully can help you I
have a service as well and I work with a
lot of brands who are trying to target
the entrepreneur community and I'll
create content for them so as an example
one client hired me to write 300 to 500
words for their blog and there was a
great gig so I started doing that but I
want more than just the 300 to 500 words
and I'll often write 1500 words so 3
times more than what they expected and
then I'll help promote it so I'll tell
my newsletter list about it I'll do a
YouTube video about it I'll put it in my
forums and put it on Twitter and
Facebook and drive people to that post
as well and not a lot more value than
what they expected of just somebody
writing a post for them and as a result
they want to keep doing work with me and
then they tell other companies that they
were partnered up with and other people
see the results of it and I ended up
having a lot more business on my hand
and as you start getting more people
coming into your business because they
see what great service you're providing
you could then start
increase your price a service based
business you're always going to be
limited by how much time you have right
there's only so many hours in the day
when you can operate your company and
you can expand by bringing new people on
but also your own personal time you
start changing the price you start
increasing the price because you're
adding a lot more value than just the
ordinary person who is starting up their
new company so I hope that helps you the
biggest way I think you're going to be
able to grow that business is again over
deliver so I don't know too much with
the waxing business but think about
anything you can do to add as much of
God as you can and make people love
coming to see you I want to come back
and refer their friends it's gonna be
your best bet so I hope you guys enjoyed
the video please leave your comments if
you did I'd love to hear what you have
to say and also give it a thumbs up if
you liked the video I love seeing those
thumbs ups and we'll see you for the
next episode
you